hi I'm Hannah your friendly neighborhood
wine mom and if you're anything like me
you believe that lots of wine an ATM
makes you a better month before I smell
glass because we're in the tasty kitchen
today I'm going to show you a super easy
recipe called snickerdoodle cheesecake
let's see I like to see how many
desserts I can combine into a cheesecake
to get as much dessert as possible this
is a great dessert if you can't decide
what you want to have whether you want
cheesecake our cookies it's kind of like
a two-in-one
and then also for this one you don't
have to wait a ridiculously long amount
of time for it to chill the worst part
of making cheesecakes I can't wait
overnight to eat it and this can chill
for an hour and it's good to go
this is a super important step to scrape
down everything because I have green
cheese up on the sides here that hasn't
gotten any eggs in it
[Music]
make sure to take plenty of wine breaks
we don't want to overexert yourself
we're gonna make a snickerdoodle cookie
batter if you're feeling extra lazy they
sell these pre-made as just like
snickerdoodle cookies at the grocery
store that works fine too so now it's
time for all the dry ingredients the
snickerdoodle topping it's probably at
the trickiest part you're just gonna put
little dollops on and then try to spread
it out so I'll kind of push it in my
hand a little bit and then lay it on
this is gonna go into the oven for 30 to
35 minutes at 350 degrees and that gives
you 30 to 35 minutes of time to chill I
gotta get on Facebook more so special
mom tip for anyone with kids or a spouse
or even a roommate if you want to make
these and be able to enjoy them all by
yourself put it at the bottom of the
vegetable drawer in your fridge so
that's what I got for today I'm Hannah
your friendly neighborhood wine mom and
if you make this leave it in the
comments if there's anything else you
want to see me make let me know till
next time
[Music]
[Music]